During the cold war,
an American soldier named James Joseph Dresner was stations on the demilitarized
zone between north and South Korea. One day,
he decided to simply walk over the line to the north.
He was defecting betraying his country and choosing to start a new life in an
enemy land that he knew nothing about for decades.
The United States government tried to this incident under the rug because they
were really embarrassed.
Likewise, North Korea denied having American defectors living in their country.
It wasn't until the two thousands that the truth was revealed to the public.
Some Sayres knock was brainwashed into loving North Korea.
Others say that he had simply seen the light.
So why did DRES knock defect and exactly what happened to him behind those
mysterious borderers while in today's biographics that's exactly what we're
looking into.
Many people say that the United States is the home of the American dream.
For many,
it truly is a place with opportunities unlike anywhere else in the world.
But for others, it's more like a nightmare.
James Joseph Dresner was born on November the 24th, 1941,
and raised in Richmond's Virginia, his parents,
they were poor and constantly fighting with one another over money.
Kwane DRES NA's mother had enough with her husbands and she decided to escape
the relationship.
James remembered that she packed his clothes and took him and his brother in the
car.
They began to drive for hours at a time until it was time to sleep in the back
of the car, the family had essentially become homeless.
The boys were not attending school. Of course,
and their mother continued to wander from place to place earning money by
selling herself in the streets. At night, she went drinking in the bars,
leaving James and his brother in the car alone.
Eventually her family tracked them down. Once they had reached at Lanza,
Georgia, their mother lost custody of the children, but James' father.
He did not want to be responsible for them at all.
So he sent his sons to go live with relatives.
James went to live with an aunt and his brother went to live with an uncle.
His aunt made it clear to him that she was annoyed to be forced to take on the
responsibility for raising her brother's child.
And she wanted him gone as soon as possible. Of course,
it was impossible for him to feel welcome in that home.
So he ran away all the time.
Eventually his aunt got fed up with James and took him back to his father's
house. By the time he returned, his father had already found a second wife.
However,
James' brother was already home and his father lied to his new wife saying that
he had only had one son,
the revelation that there was now another mouth defeat made his new stepmother
very angry, and they got into a heated argument.
The next morning, his father drove James to a retirement home,
a few towns away from where they lived.
He claims that they were going to visit an elderly relative. Once they arrived,
his father asked him to wait in the reception area.
He went back out to his car and he never came back.
James was now an orphan with nowhere to go,
instead of asking the nurses or the elderly retirees for help,
he left the building and stole a $20 bill.
Then he found an unattended bicycle, which he stole as well.
And he tried to run away,
but he was called by the police and they claimed that he was a juvenile
delinquent and he was almost sent to a detention center. However,
he was ultimately allowed to live at the over street.
Children's home in Glen island, Virginia,
which was run by pastor CT over street that the kids' nicknamed big Papa.
He loved spending time there and finally felt as though he had been welcomed
into a surrogate family. James made friends with some of the other orphans,
including a boy named Sonny Jetta, who to describe James DRES knock.
He had absolutely nothing.
He had nothing to call his own except the clothes that were on his back.
For children who are born in James DRES knock situation.
There are very few work opportunities.
His parents had often kept him out of school for so long when he was young,
that he had a very hard time catching up to his peers.
During an interview years later, he claims that he was illiterate though.
It may have been an exaggeration.
He enlisted in the us army at 17 years old because it was the best chance for
him to have any kind of career or learn a life skill.
He believed that by joining the army,
he would've more freedom to travel the world and have options in a career.
But unfortunately what he felt was the exact opposite.
The army had strict rules and regulations.
They controlled where he would be stations and for how long drill sergeants were
yelling at him constantly.
And he realized that what he actually wanted was a normal life with a wife and
children.
He wanted that idea of the perfect American dream of the happy little family
that he never got to have as a kid during leave from the army,
he went back to Virginia.
He was now 18 years old and married a young woman that he met at church named
Kathleen Ringwood.
They had only known each other for a short period of time before the army
stationed him in west Germany. For two years,
he was separated from his wife for so long that she cheated on him when he was
away.
He received a rather cold letter from her in the mail saying that she'd found a
new lover and a did a force during an interview.
Jaar bitterly mentioned the fact that he had had so many opportunities to cheat
on Kathleen while he was stationed in Germany.
And that most soldiers had prostitutes,
but he remained celibate for over two years because he was loyal to her.
Jaar must have felt that all of the images of the happy American families of the
1950s and 1960s was just propaganda. If the American dream existed,
he couldn't find it.
He returns to Virginia just long enough to file the paperwork for divorce,
without anything, keeping him there.
He decided to reenlist in the army for another term. He said,
the time I left Richmond, I was fed up. I didn't want nothing.
If I died or lived, I didn't care.
The Korean war had been over for more than a decade. And yet the fighting,
it had never stopped. There is a two and a half mile wide,
125 mile long stretch of lands between north and South Korea,
which is known as the demilitarized zone or the DMZ for short in 1962,
James DRES knock was stationed at the DMZ.
And he was shocked at the fact that even in time of peace,
he very well may die defending the border.
He was incredibly depressed and had lost any hope for a future outside of the
army.
So he decided to spend all of the money that he earns hiring prostitutes in the
south Korean villages and drinking.
He was now 20 years old and his days were an endless cycle of taking orders,
doing the bare minimum effort and letting loose as soon as he could take time
off one night, just not wanted to go and see one of his girlfriends,
but his commanding officers would not allow him to leave.
Whenever he felt like it.
He was so fed up with having to obey orders all the time that he forged his
Sergeant signature on a pass and snuck out to the village at night.
The next morning, August the 15th, 19 62, 1 of his commanding officers,
captain Thomas bra was trying to reprimand him for sneaking Outre kn snapped.
You can't touch me at a pass.
Obviously, Brian wasn't stupid.
He already knew that TRN knock had forged the signature captain.
Brian told him to come back to his office at 3:00 PM.
He plans a file that charged sheets and having court martialed,
DRN nor felt as if he had absolutely no future,
especially since he had absolutely no money to his name and no home to go to in
the distance. North Korea had built a city that they called the peace village.
They played music and urged south Koreans to defect so that they could enjoy the
beautiful communist country from DRES no's perspective.
It looked far more advanced compared to South Korea. The,
that same day DRES mark snuck out during lunch break.
It was still broad daylight.
And he began walking down the road towards North Korea.
He knew that there were landmines all around him,
but he cared so little about his own life, that he was willing to take the risk.
Once the Americans noticed that he was leaving,
they started to shout after him to come back.
He turned around and shot into the air, which scared everyone.
They believed that he had gone AOL and was tried to attack them.
He continued walking quickly towards North Korea and he never looked back.
He said, yes, I was afraid. But at the same time, life wasn't so precious.
The north Korean soldiers were stations on their side of the DMZ.
And from their perspective,
they saw a very tall and powerful looking white man coming towards them.
They were all ordered to take battle stations and group the soldiers surrounded
him. They pointed their guns and their nets at him.
It was clear from the way that they looked at him that many of them wanted to
kill him on the spot. This was the American monster. They had been warned about.
The squad commander told them all to calm down.
They blindfolded him and they took him back to that base.
James Dresner was interrogated and he calmly complied to answering all of their
questions without resistance. Since he was just a private last class,
he did not know anything that the north Koreans themselves didn't already know
the next morning he worked to a voice speaking to him in English,
tres Dre I'm AB she still half asleep.
James probably thought everything had been a bad dream. He owns, I don't know,
an AB. She, the man replied Larry a AB sheer.
You didn't see me in the newspapers.
It turns out that James Dresner was not the first American soldier who had
chosen to defect a North Korea, a young man named Larry Allen.
Abshire had a similar backstory to James Dresner except that he was in trouble
because he was caught smoking the wild marijuana that grew on the north Korean
border. He got fed up with the rules and decided to cross the border.
Another man, Jerry Wayne perished defected. A few months later in 1963,
North Korea began sending paper flyers over the border of the DMZ offering
financial incentives for Americans who brought them weapons and secrets.
This is what convinced a man named Sergeant Charles Robert Jenkins he'd affected
in 1965 and showed up carrying an M 14 rifle.
He was given an award into celebration in front of a large crowd.
The government tried to use these men as examples that the United States in
South Korea must be an awful place to live.
If these men were willing to flee the country,
James began to tell the north people about the dark history of American slavery
and how so many people became homeless. Despite their hard work,
since he was so willing to participate in their propaganda.
The north Koreans asked James DRES knock to speak over the loud speakers in
English.
He started to say that if more American soldiers came over to North Korea,
they would be treated like Kings, but living in North Korea,
it wasn't all shined.
It was very uncomfortable for these men to live as the only white people in the
entire country,
especially since propaganda had taught them that Americans were evil.
The four men could not walk down the street without people staring at them and
whispering. They were not allowed to marry any of the north Korean women.
And they quickly realized that it would be impossible to have a normal life Abha
parish. And Jen all agreed with Dresner that it was time to plan and
escape.
In 1966, all four of the men decided that it was time to leave.
They visited the Soviet embassy and Kung yang asking for asylum so that they
could be transferred to live in the USSR. Dresner said,
we thought because they were white people too. They would accept,
but the Russians didn't treat us good.
They notified the Korean government and the men were taken back into custody.
According to Dresner, the Koreans did not punish them for trying to leave.
In fact,
they felt guilty that they had made the four men feel so unwelcome and decided
it was time to try harder to educate them on how to speak Korean and learn the
ways of their culture compared to how he was treated for his mistake.
In the us army, he felt very grateful for their mercy and their understanding.
Keep in mind that at this time,
Kim sung was actually making more economic progress in North Korea compared to
the south back in South Korea,
most people were still living in extreme poverty and working at farmers pong
yang had skyscrapers, a sports stadium,
and frankly of smiling people seeing this spectacularity was pre that communism
really just may be the better choice compared to capitalism without any contact
with the outside world.
These men would have no way of knowing that the United States had been able to
go to the moon or any of the other accomplishments that were going on in their
home country. The men were told that it was in the best interest of everyone.
If they lived separately from average north Korean people,
they had minds who would come to ask every day,
if they needed anything like personal servants,
that would go to the supermarkets and retrieve anything that they might need.
If they wanted to go anywhere, they would be chauffeur directly to these places.
The four men lived every day, like it was an extended vacation.
They would read novels, go for a swim in the river, smoke cigarettes, drink,
get amble and tell one,
another stories about life back in America to James Dresner.
It was everything he ever wanted. This was his definition of freedom.
He felt as though he was being treated like a king,
but to Sergeant Charles Jenkins,
he felt like a prisoner who had failed his first attempt to escape.
And the mission was not complete.
Since Jenkins was the highest ranking officer among them.
He began acting like their leader.
He tried to tell the three younger men what they should do and what they
shouldn't. According Toreno this made the other two men happy.
They were used to being given orders in the army and they probably felt some
comfort to have an older man telling them that they would continue planning
their escape, but DRES knock. He didn't like being bossed around.
He got into a fist fight with Jenkins and punched him until he fell on the
ground. After this incident,
the other men started to isolate themselves from DRES knock.
In 1972, the four men were fluent enough in speaking Korean to have north Korean
citizenship,
they were allowed to leave their compounds and have their own apartments,
food rations, and transportation. The leader son,
Kim Jong ill had not taken his father's place as the new dictator,
even though such things were forbidden to the average citizen,
ill indulged in Hollywood movies.
And it was his dream to become a film director. Of course, if you,
the son of the dictator, you can do whatever you want.
Kim Jonel needed someone to play the villains.
And that's where the American men came in. In 1978,
all four of the men started in a 20 part drama called unsung heroes.
James draught played a character named Arthur.
Kim Joni explained to his people that in order to portray a villain effectively,
an accident needs to have a lot of patriotism for their country.
After hearing north Korean people stopped thinking of these American defects as
the enemy and began to see them as national heroes. Now,
when he went out in public,
people began to address him as Arthur and they happily gave him free food drinks
gifts. In the 1980s,
he began to teach English classes at the university of pong yang.
Most of the information they had struggled in from the outside world about
advances in science, technic were written in English.
Sores NA's help was actually vital to their translations. One evening,
James Dresner went to a restaurant and spotted a beautiful Brunett woman named
doer bomber. She was the first European woman he had seen in years.
So he began to talk to her. He didn't waste any time asking her out on a date.
She agreed and they ended up getting married and having two children.
It was late.
It revealed that Noer bomber may have actually been kidnapped by the north
Korean government.
Since that she was planted in this restaurant with the intentions of setting
them up together. However, James DRES not claimed that she was there by choice.
Even years later in 2014,
her brother Gabriel bomber demanded answers at the UN human rights council.
Her family was never allowed to communicate with her. So they never you,
if she was kidnapped or if she chose to defect,
she died of lung cancer before she could have a see her loved ones. Again,
Larry Allen AB married a Thai woman named Anjo.
She began working as a massage therapist in Bangkok.
Her roommates say that one day she'd left the apartment to get her hair done at
the beauty parlor and never came back.
Pan Android's friends and family never knew that she had been kidnapped was
living in North Korea.
Larry Abshire died in 1983 from a heart attack at 40 years old during the
1990s, Kim Jong ill became dictator.
And there was a huge famine in North Korea known as the arduous March.
No one is sure how many people died during this time.
But some estimate that it is in the millions,
the four American men were celebrities now and considered members of the elite
class.
So they never had to give up their food rations or suffer like the lower class
people, James and diners' two sons.
Theodore James grew up and attended the foreign language college and pong yang.
During his interview with the BBC DRES kn said that if he had stayed in the
United States,
he knows that he could never have afforded to send his children to college.
And he had absolutely no regrets for defecting,
not long after the death of his first wife,
James Dresner went back to that same restaurant and met his third wife.
Her father was a diplomat from the Togolese Republic and had got a Korean woman
pregnant as a mixed raced woman.
She was seen as undesirable for Korean men to marry.
So James Dresner married her and they had a child together.
James Wayne parish married a woman named Crear from Lebanon and he eventually
passed away. She was still alive to give her testimony during BBC documentary.
According to her, she came to North Korea as a tourist, fell in love with par,
got pregnant and decided to stay.
Triar says that she was never kidnapped and just happy living in North Korea
parish died 1998 when he was 54 years old,
James Dresner and Charles Jenkins were the only two American defectors left from
their original group. Even after all of those years, the two were still at odds.
Dresner loved life in North Korea and Jenkins still felt very much like a
prisoner in 80 Jenkins was 40 years old and de met a 21 year old Japanese woman
named OMA SOGA.
She was not afraid to bluntly tell him that she had been kidnapped and wanted to
go home Jenkins and SOGA bonded over their home sickness.
And they fell in love and got married.
They lived in an apartment next door to an pan Android.
The two kidnapped to women became very close friends.
And the three of them all secretly grief for their home countries pan was
eventually able to escape after marrying an east German diplomats and the north
Korean government agreed to let her go. In 2002,
the north Korean government gave mercy to hit SOGA and several other Japanese
women who had been kidnapped and allowed them to go back to Japan to visit their
family. They were supposed to return, but obviously he never went back. In 2004,
the Japanese,
his government was able to help reunite Charles Jenkins with her Tony SOGA.
He and his two daughters were finally able to escape and move to Japan.
Once he was free.
Charles Jenkins wrote an autobiography called to tell the truth in his book,
Jenkins claims that the north Korean government turned James dress knock into
their muscle and that he beat him bloody on at least 30 different occasions.
They also cut off the skin of all his us army to choose without using
anesthetic, even DRES knock admitted to the tattoo. Part of the story,
revealing his scars during a documentary saying that everyone volunteered to
have them removed.
Charles Jenkins also claimed that the government wanted all of them to give
birth to foreign children who were loyal to North Korea so that they could
become spies.
James DRES knock continued to deny all of Jenkins claims saying that he was
simply playing up the situation in order to sell his book. His two sons,
Theodore James, and out full grown men,
and they have taken their father's place playing American villains in north
Korean films.
He died in 2016 at 74 years old president George W.
Bush was asked to make a decision on what to do about Charles Jenkins' defection
in the 1960s. After hearing the whole story,
Bush decided that Jenkins would serve just 30 days in prison.
And his rank was demoted to private.
He was granted Japanese citizenship in 2008,
despite the fact that they were manipulated into being together,
he and he told truly did love one another because they stayed together for the
rest of his life. Charles Jenkins died in 2017 at 77 years old.
Unfortunately we may never know the whole truth about what happened behind
closed doors to think James Dr. Knock was brainwashed by the north Koreans,
or is this a situation where two people truly could have a vastly different view
of an almost identical situation? Well, let us know in the comments,
what you think, and please do subscribe for more videos, just like this.
Also give us a, like if you enjoyed it and as always, thanks for watching.